شكرا ريم اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام نتابع
واياكم في تغطيتنا من العربيه المخصصه
بجلها للاحداث في السودان نبدا بالعناوين
خلينا نقول بالوعي او بادراك الطرفين
موافقه طرفي النزاع على محادثات لتثبيت
الهدنه
اشتباكات عنيفه في احياء متفرقه في
الخرطوم وسط تحليق للطيران الحربي
الامم المتحده تؤكد فرار ثلاثه وسبعين الف
شخص من السودان والصليب الاحمر يؤكد ان
كارثه انسانيه اكبر قادمه
وتتابعون معنا ايضا في هذه الساعه
النقابات الفرنسيه تؤكد خروج مليونين و300
الف متظاهر ضد مكرون والحكومه تقول اقل من
800 الف
[موسيقى]
الهدوء النسبيه الذي عاشته مدن الخرطوم في
الهدنه السابقه اصبح الان امرا بعيد
المنال بعد ان تواصلت الاشتباكات
الاشتباكات العنيفه في مناطق مختلفه في
الخرطوم اليوم تم رصد الطيران الحربي وهو
يقصف مواقع في الخرطوم ايضا افادت مصادر
بتحركات لقوات الدعم السريعه يقول المبعوث
الاممي الى السودان فولكربيرس في لقاء خاص
مع العربيه يقول ان طرفي النزاع لم يلتزم
ابدا بالهدنه بشكل كامل لكن على سبيل
الامل يقول بارتس انه تم التوافق على
اجراء محادثات فنيه بين الجيش والدعم
السريع من اجل تثبيت الهدنه وحتى موعد
اجراء هذه المحادثات ربما ستظل هذه
المشاهد هي السائده في الخرطوم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
واضحه هنا ما بين الدعم السريع
والقوات الشعب المسلحه
نسمع الان بوضوح
منطقه تحديدا
في حديث خاص بالعربيه اذا قال المبعوث
الاممي الى السودان فولكربرت ان العمل جار
لوضع التفاصيل اللوجستيه لمفاوضات السودان
مع الامريكيين والسعوديين ورجح ان تجري
مفاوضات الحل في السعوديه مشيرا الى ان
الاولويه الان لوقف اطلاق النار اكد
المبعوث الاممي ان طرفي الصراع ادركا
خطوره الوضع ووافقا على محادثات فنيه
للوصول الى وقف لاطلاق النار
في ادراك اكثر حاليا انه الانتصار العسكري
غير ممكن
الا
للسعر عالي جدا وهذا الدمار مدينه الخاتوم
ويمكن فقدان كل البلد
الفقدان وقال المبعوث الاممي للعربيه ان
طرفي النزاع في السودان باتاي يدركان ان
الانتصار العسكريه لن يكون الا بثمن باهظ
على السودان
في الاسبوع الاخير تكريما تغيير
باللهجه ويمكن تغيير تغيير خلينا بنقول
بالوعي او بادراك الطرفين لخطور الوضع
لانه وين بتعرف يعني بالاسبوع الاول
الاسبوع الثاني
فالجهتين كانوا
يعني كانوا يعبروا عن تاكيد انهم سيمتصرون
على الجانب الثاني
فكانوا يطلبون باستسلام الجانب الثاني الى
اخره انا بتائده انه في ادراك اكثر حاليا
انه الالتصار العسكري غير ممكن
الا لسار
عالي جدا
على النقيضه من ذلك اكد الرئيس الكينيم
روتو ان طرفي الصراع في السودان بل اكد ان
طرفي الصراع رفضا الاستجابه لدعوات ايجاد
والاتحاد الافريقي والمجتمع الدولي لوقف
اطلاق النار واضاف خلال اجتماع مع مسؤولين
افارقه واماميين ان الازمه الانسانيه في
السودان وصلت الى مستويات كارثيه وسط نقص
في المياه والغذاء والادويه مشيرا الى ان
عدد النازحين مستمر في الارتفاع مع فرار
المزيد الى دول الجوار
على الارض اتهم الدعم السريع الجيش
السوداني بتحويل مستشفى السلاح الطبي
بعمرمان الى منصه للقصف المدفعي واشار في
بيان له الى ان القصف المدفعي العشوائي من
مستشفى السلاح الطبي ادى لمقتل واصابه
كوادر طبيه بحسب تاكيدات الدعم السريع
واضاف ايضا ان طيران الجيش لا يزال يحلق
في سماء الخرطوم ولا يزال يقصف احياء
سكنيه
وكانت جيش السوداني قد اكد في بيان له ان
قوات الدعم السريعه حشدت اكثر من 65 الف
عنصر ومن الفين مركبه للهجوم على الخرطوم
قبل الخامس عشر من ابريل لكن الجيش استطاع
التصدي لمحاولات انتشارهم مشيرا الى ان
الجيش تمكن في غضون اسبوعين من القتال ان
يخفض قدرات الدعم السريع القتاليه الى
النصف مضيفا انه تم احباطه عده تحركات
لتعزيزات عسكريه لقوات الدعم السريع قادمه
من اتجاه الغرب الى الخرطوم
في المقابل نشرت قوات الدعم السريع لقطات
فيديو تظهر انتشار عناصرها في مبنى القصر
الجمهوري في وسط العاصمه الخرطوم وقالت
قوه الدعم السريع انها تسيطر تماما على
القصر الجمهوري ومحيطه في الخرطوم
بالاضافه الى مبنى الاذاعه والتلفزيون في
اندرمان كما اكد احد قاده الدعم السريع ان
سيطرتهم على القصر الجمهوري تاتي ضمن
مساعي الدعم السريع للحفاظ على ثروات
الشعب السوداني
قوات الدعم السريع من داخل القصر الجمهوري
نود ان نوصل رساله
لشعبنا الكريم ولشرفاء القوات المسلحه
اولا نناشد كل الشرفاء في قوات الشعب
المسلح بان هذا العمل الذي زدت فيه القوات
المسلحه هو عمل يخدم افراد واشخاص محددين
في القوات المسلحه والغرض الاساسي منه
النازل دارين السولو على سلطه الشعب
السوداني وعن طريق كوميتو نحن الان في
قوات الدعم السريع بالناشد كل القوات
المسلحه وشرفاء القوات المسلحه بانه نحن
ما عاد بالنسبه لهم وانما نحن نريد ان
نحافظ على سلطه الشعب ونقول للشعب
السوداني تواجد قوات الدعم السريع في داخل
القصر وفي كل ولايه الخرطوم القرض الاساسي
منه الحفاظ على سلطه الشعب
معنا من اندرمان صحفي في مكتب العربيه في
السودان شهد نادر اهلا بك معنا شهدي اولا
كيف هو الوضع الان على الارض حيث انت في
ام درمان
مرحبا
منتصف طوال ساعات منتصف نهار اليوم
ظل تحليق مكثف للطيران الحربي الطائرات
المقاتله حلقت بشكل مكثف اليوم اصوات
المضادات الارضيه اشتباكات بها الاسلحه
الخفيفه بحسب شهود عيان
جنوب مدينه ام درمان ادخن في شرق مدينه
درمان وتحديدا في مدينه الخرطوم البحري
اتهام من قبل قوات الدعم السريعه
الجيش بقصر الطبيه التي في التي كانت التي
كانت في الاساسيه سلاح المظلات الجيش
السوداني والذي تم تحويله منذ حوالي اربع
سنوات الى وحده طبيه اليوم في بيان اتهمت
قوات الدعم السريعه القوات المسلحه بقص
هذه هذه الوحده كذلك قص في ضاحيه كافوري
في مدينه الخرطوم بحري اشتباكات استمرت
لساعات طويله بشكل
متقطع شي ضاحيه سرقه النيل وكذلك مدينه
الخرطوم
مدينه الخرطوم شهدت اشتباكات في عده مناطق
هو اليوم الاول في الهدنه مع بعض تمديدها
مضى بشكل مقاهر وعكسي يوم امس الذي كان
فيه هدوم ملحوظ واطمئنان النسبي لدى
المواطنين في عمولايه وفي مدينه ام درمان
التي قراناها للتو اشير فقط الى ان
الخارجيه السعوديه تقول الان ان عدد
الرعايه الذين اجلتهم المملكه من السودان
ان العدد
549 اشخاص اضافه الى اجلاء 225 مواطنا
سعوديا تم اجلائهم من السودان اذا اضافه
الى 225 مواطنا سعوديا تم اجلائهم من
السودان وفقا لاخر ما تقوله الخارجيه
السعوديه
اتابع معك شهدي من الحديث عن موضوع
المستشفى دعم سريع اتهم الجيش السوداني
بتحويل مستشفى السلاح الطبي باندرمان الى
منصه للقصف المدفعي
نظرا لشح المعلومات احيانا ولتضارب نسال
ماذا يقول الطرف الاخر عن هذا الموضوع
يصدر بيان بنهايه اليوم حول عموم الموقف
العمليات في
البلاد حتى الان لم تصدر عن العلاقات
المسلحه بيان او تعميم ولكن متوقع ان يصدر
بنهايه
بنهايه اليوم ولكن ود الاشاره
الصوت عم يتقطع شهدي نحاول مره اخرى معك
تود الاشاره الى ماذا
الى بعض المواطنين هناك تنامي في مواطنين
الطروا للخروج من منازلهم وتحديدا في حي
المورده وهو حي في جنوب ام درمان قباله
جسر النيل الابيض قباله السلاح الطبي
حددني احد الذين يسكنون هناك بانهم اضطروا
لي الخروج جراء الاصوات الاصوات ذوي
الاسلحه الثقيله وخلافه
الكثير يحكى عن حالات يعني اخلاء اجباري
للمنازل عن يعني احتلال جهه من هنا او جهه
من هناك لبعض المنازل واضطرار سكانها
لاخلائها لاضافه الى عمليات نهب وسلب الى
ما هنالك اريد ان اتوقف معك الان شهدي عند
موضوع اخر كنا ذكرناه وهو لجهه ما قاله
الجيش عن حشد قوات الدعم السريع لاكثر من
65 الف عنصر اض افه الى الفين مركبه
للهجوم على الخرطوم قبل 15 من ابريل اي
قبل اندلاع هذه الاحداث هل هناك اي رد من
الدعم السريع على هذا الكلام
نعم حتى الان قوه
القوات الدعم السريع في بيانها فقط هي
اشاره الى تحويل جسر عفوا السلاح الطبي
لمنصه اطلاقه صواريخ لم تعلق على هذا على
هذا الامر ما قبل ما جرى في الخامس عشر من
امريكا كانت هناك احترام
الاصطدام للتصريحات ما بين قائد الجيش عبد
الفتاح البرهان وكذلك الفريق
كان هناك كان كان هناك تمه تحشيد ولكن كان
بشكل غير مرئي تنام هذا الامر الى وصول
قوات الدعم الشركه كما تعلم الى قاعده
مروي وبغداد شجره هنا صحيح بعد ثلاثه ايام
طيب استفيد من وجودك معنا ايضا لاسالك عما
قالته قوات الدعم السريع عن سيطرتها
الكامله على القصر الجمهوري وعلى محيطه في
الخرطوم يعني رغم بعد المسافه ولكن ايضا
اذا كان هناك معلومات لديك وكذلك عن مبنى
الاذاعه والتلفزيون في ام درمان ما هو
الواقع على الارض
نعم فيما يلي مساله القصر الجمهوري كما
تعلم ان هناك تلك المناطق هي مناطق
اشتباكات لا يستطيع احد ان يصل اليها
وكذلك مقرا الاذاعه والتلفزيون الذي ظل
محل اشتباكات بشكل متواصل منذ يوم الخامس
عشر من ابريل منذ لحاله الاحداث وحتى
اليوم اليوم اصوات المضادات كانت تاتي من
منطقه او محيطه الاذاعه والتلفزيون بشكل
كان كان فيه بشكل متقطع ولكن كانت تاتي من
هناك لربما كان هناك اشتباك حينما كان
الطيران يحلق في سماء مدينه قرمان منتصف
النهار شكرا جزيلا لك شهدي نادر الصحفي في
مكتب العربيه في السودان من ام درمان شكرا
جزيلا على كل هذه المعلومات تحياتي اليك
لازم اشتغل يعني في في ظروف
السلع زاد في زياده اي حاجه زايده لازم
انا اشتغل
لي زي ساعتين ثلاثه وقفل لانه البلد ما
امنه صعب
[موسيقى]
يحاول يشتغل القواد ما حبابه والخوف ما
منه فايده
[موسيقى]
اعلن مسؤول اللاجئين في الامم المتحده
توقعاته بفرار ما يفوق الثمن 100 الف شخص
من السودان اثرا نزاع في البلاد كما اضاف
المسؤول ان 33 الف شخص فالروم متجهين الى
دول الجوار وفي السياق ذاته عبر منسق
الامم المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه عن مخاوفه
من امتداد ازمه السودان الى دول الجوار
واعلن المنسق ان الوضع الانساني في البلاد
يتجه الى نحو كارثي وان شحنه من الادويه
عالقه على الحدود ولم تدخل السودان بعد
كارثه شامله يتجه اليها الوضع الانساني في
السودان
منسق الامم المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه في
السودان وصف الوضع بالكارثه متخوفا من
امتداد الازمه لدول الجوار
[موسيقى]
تصريحات داعمه لما سبق ادلى بها مسؤول
اللاجئين في الامم المتحده متوقعا فرار
اكثر من 800 الف شخص من السودان
بالاضافه الى 73 الف شخص لاذو بالفرار الى
دول الجوار
هروب جماعي من المعارك والوضع الصحي
المزري مع استمرار خروج المشافي عن الخدمه
ومقص التجهيزات
بينما تواجه شحنه ادويه من الصحه العالميه
عوائق للدخول الى البلاد
هذا وحذر مدير الاعلام لدى لجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر في السودان من ان الاوضاع
الانسانيه سيئه جدا وهناك كوارث عديده
الامر الذي يدفع بالصليب الاحمر الى
التركيز على القطاع الصحي لايصال
المساعدات الطبيه
الاوضاع الانسانيه سيئه جدا وهناك كوارث
الاولويه القصوى بالنسبه للصليب الاحمر هي
القطاع الصحي حيث تعاني المستشفيات من عدم
توفر المياه والكهرباء وانها غير قادره
على العمل لذلك المستشفيات بحاجه الى
مساعدات طبيه كبيره جدا وعلينا البدء
بتقديم الدعم المطلوب وتوفير المستلزمات
الطبيه واللقاحات اللازمه
دخلت عمليات اجلاء رعايه دول الاجنبيه من
شرق السودان صوب ميناء جده وعبر مطار
بورتسودان يومها العاشر اكثر من 16 الف
طالب اجلاء غادروا البلاد من خلال شرق
السودان خلال الايام الماضيه غير ان الاف
من السوريين واليمنيين
ومقيمين السودانيين في عدد من الدول
العربيه يواجهون صعوبات في سبيل مغادرتهم
السودان العربيه ترصد الواقعه من شرق
السودان
عشره ايام مضت على اول عمليه اجلاء لرعايه
دول الاجنبيه من شرق السودان نحو مختلف
الدول العالم عبر ميناء بورسودان وعبر
مرها الدولي اكثر من 20 رحله بحريه تمت
حتى الان ونحو 45 رحله جويه من مطار
بورسودان الدولي تستمر عمليات الاجلاء دون
توقف غير ان اوضاع الرعايه السوريين
المطالبين بجلائهم تشكل استثناء هنا عم
نطلب
من الوحده نروح نحن اي بلد
فيزا اربيل العراق مصر اي اي مكان ما حدا
سال علينا العيال في الشوارع النساء
الشباب مضى معه مصاري هاي ما تصرف الحمد
لله الشعب السوداني ما هو مقصر ابدا لا من
اكل لا من ملبس لا من ماء
هذا الوضع اضبط الاخرى تشهدها المنافذ نحو
الخارج حيث يواجه السودانيون المقيمون في
عدد من الدول ظروفا صعبه يقول كثير منهم
ان اوضاعهم لا تحتمل تاخر اجراءات
مغادرتهم للسودان نحن اننا زيارات يعني في
ناس غ
اماتها والحكومه واقفه والبلد واقفه دي
مشكله
فبالناشد كل السلطات يا جماعه انه لو في
امكانيه توفر لنا بواخر نحن بحقنا بتذاكر
بنشتري كل السودانيين
مستطيعين انهم يدفعوا حق التذاكر بس ما
موجوده بواخر نحن كسودانيين مقيمين في
السعوديه نناشد السلطات السودانيه
والسلطات السعوديه انه يسرعوا في اجراءات
اجلانا من مدينه بورسودان الى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه لانه عندنا طلبه عندهم
جامعات وعندهم اسر
الشفقانين علوم شديد ولازم يصلون باسرع
وقت
للمواجهات المسلحه ارتدادات مختلفه يامل
كثيرون هنا ان لا تتمدد لتشمل قطاعات اخرى
نزار البغداوي لقناتي العربيه والحدث
مدينه بورسودان الشرقيه السودان
معنى من الخرطوم عطاف محمد مختار رئيس
تحرير صحيفه السودانيه اهلا بك معنا استاذ
مختار في هذه التغطيه المستمره من العربيه
واريد ان افهم منك طبيعه فهمكم لما تفضل
به فولكرز اليوم في مقابلته الخاصه
بالعربيه عندما تحدث عن محادثات فنيه كما
سماها بين الطرفين
تسمعني الان
ما تفسيركم للمحادثات الفنيه كما وصفها
اليوم في مقابلته الخاصه مع العربيه
يتحدث لصحيفه شرق الاوسط عن سيطره شبه
كامله على مدن العاصمه الثلاث خرطوم
الخرطوم بحري واندرمان ويقول ستكون هناك
عوده للاتفاق الايطالي بعد سقوط او
استسلام قياده القوات المسلحه يعني ليس
هناك الكثير مما يجري في خطابه بامكانيه
احياء محادثات قد تنجح ان كانت فنيه او
جوهريه
الاهداف الدعم السريع الاستراتيجيه في هذه
الحرب واتباعه في بعض التكتيكات المضيف
هدف الاستراتي للسيطره على قياده الجيش
الرياضه
كلها يعني لم يستطيع تنفيذ اي منها
الحروب اول عمليات العسكريه باهدافها
والجيش عليه الطريق ودقا معسكرات وخطوط
لذلك خارج انتشار نراه في في عدد من المدن
الخرطوم وفي عدد من المناطق لن تستطيع
العوده
من عدد المؤتراضيه تتعرض هذا كله ما في
الامر لكن حديث
ايضا حدث عن انه النبي اخر 490
الان اصبح منهم ثلاثه فقط
اكتفي معك بهذا القدر للاسف بسبب يعني
الصوت من المصدر شكرا جزيلا لك عطاف محمد
مختار رئيس تحرير صحيفه سوداني من الخرطوم
لعلنه يعني نتقابل في مرات اخرى ان شاء
الله تحياتي اليك استطلعت العربيه راى
سودانيين على الحدود المصريه السودانيه
قرروا العوده الى بلادهم من مصر الى
السودان رغم من السودان الى مصر رغم
استمرار الحرب بيقولوا الوضع بقى احسن
شويه واحنا شايفين في قنوات الاجتماعي ان
الوضع حسن ويعني ما فيش مشاكل دلوقتي يعني
ما فيش حاجه يعني فعشان كده اضطرينا نرجع
بلدنا يعني انا مش خايفه انا اللي عليا مش
خايفه
وهي مشكله انا هي دي مشكله
ما بين شخصين
معنى من الخرطوم وراسل العربيه سالم
الهاشمي اهلا بك سالم الوضع الان على
الارض
سالم تسمعني
الان تفضل
نعم بالنسبه للاوضاع على الارض الان بدا
الهدوء يعم الان بعد
يوم كان مليء بالاصوات العاليه للمدافع
ومضاده الطائرات وقص الطائرات كذلك لمناطق
متفرقه من العاصمه
بمدنها الثلاثه كان خصوصا مكثفا هذه المره
في المناطق التي تتمركز بها قوات الدعم
السريعه القصف الذي كان في الخرطوم
وشاهدناه كان في محيط مطار الخرطوم وكذلك
محيط القياده العامه للجيش
الى ذلك كان هنالك قصف في مدينه ام درمان
ومناطق متفرقه من مدينه بحري ابرزها ايضا
كافر مربع سته وكذلك بالقرب من
المنطقه الصناعيه في مدينه بحري وسط مدينه
بحري هذه ابرز المناطق التي تم استهدافها
وهي مناطق تتمركز بها قوات من الدعم
السريع وكان الجيش السوداني اخر نهار
اليوم في السعاده الاخيره من النهار قد
بحمله مكثفه بالطائرات في مناطق متفرقه من
العاصمه الخرطوم وهذه الحمله اشارت الرعب
مدى المواطنين حتى وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي ضجه في هذه الاحداث من كل
الاتجاهات باعاد يكون كل ولايات الخرطوم
استمعت الى هذه الطائرات واستمعت الى هذا
القصد واستمعت ايضا الى مضادات الطائرات
التي شكلت رعبا حقيقيه لدى المواطنين الان
هدوء نسبي شوارع في هذه المنطقه وفي في
مدينه الخرطوم في شرقيه الخرطوم تبدو
الشوارع الخاليه الان من الماره حرص من
المواطنين على انه كما اعتدنا منذ بدا
الاحداث ان يكونوا حريصين في الليل بعدم
الخروج تكاد تكون الشوارع خاليه من الماره
وكذلك المحل التجاريه مغلقه بالكامل
سالم ما حقيقه ما قالته قوات الدعم
السريعه عن السيطره الكامله على القصر
الجمهوري بناء على ما يقوله الجيش على
الاقل حتى الان
[موسيقى]
التلفزيونيه فيصعب جدا النظر لهذا الامر
بهذه الطريقه لكن ظلت قوات الدعم السريع
تقول انها تسيطر على القصر الجمهوري وظل
الجيش السوداني يرد كذلك في حتى في
القياده العامه للجيش شهدنا هذا الامر
كذلك في مناطق متفرقه ايضا انه تم تصلي
على هذه المنطقه ولم يتم السيطره عليها
ياتي البيان بالنفي ياتي البيان بالاثبات
وهذا بهذا الشكل يعني بين تبادل البيانات
لكن بالمجمل نعم بالمجمل نحن يجب ان نقول
ان في هذه المناطق التي تحدث عنها مثلا
الدعم السريع اذا تحدثنا عن موضوع
القنصلنا نستمع الى اصوات مضادات الطائرات
ونسمع كذلك المدافع ونصر المدافع الثقيله
والخفيفه كلها ايضا في محيط القصر الرئاسي
على مر هذه الايام سنعود اليك لاحقا في
سياق تغطيتنا شكرا جزيلا على كل هذه
المعلومات للان مراسل العربيه من الخرطوم
سالم الهاشمي
البيت الابيض نشرنا طائرات مراقبه لحمايه
اجلاء الامريكيين من السودان الوضع على
الارض هناك متقلب ولا يسمح بعمليات اجلاء
جديده نتشارك مع حلفائنا مع حلفائنا
المعلومات الاستخباريه حول الصراع في
السودان ونتواصل مع طرفي الصراع في
السودان بشكل مكثف لوقف اطلاق النار وفقا
لما يقوله البيت الابيض في هذه الاخبار
العاجله عن السودان اذا ونتابع منه
وتحديدا من عمليات الاجلاء من مدينه
بورتسودان مع مراسل العربيه نزار البغداوي
غير جاهز معنا اذا سنعود اليه لاحقا ان
شاء الله في سياق هذه التغطيه نقابه اطباء
السودان اعلنت عن ارتفاع عادات قتل
الاشتباكات الدائره في البلاد الى 436
شخصا كما اكدت ان عدد المصابين ارتفع الى
ما يزيد عن 2175 شخصا في صفوف المدنيين
نقابه الاطباء السودانيين تحدثت او قالت
ايضا ان هناك الكثير من الاصابات والوفيات
غير مشموله في هذا الحصر بسبب صعوبه
الوصول للمستشفيات مضيفه ان الاشتباكات
القبليه في مدينه الجنينه بولايه غرب
دارفور اسفرت عن سقوط 94 قتيلا مشيره الى
ان جميع المستشفيات لا تعمل في المدينه
حتى اللحظه
نظام الرعايه الصحيه على وشك الانهيار
الصحه العالميه اكدت وقوع 26 هجوما على
مرافق الرعايه الصحيه منذ اندلاع الصراع
بالسودان
وتقول ان المستشفيات تعرضت لقصف واغلق
ثلثاها في الخرطوم نقابه اطباء السودان
حذرت من الانهيار الكامل لنظام الرعايه
الصحيه
الصليب الاحمر العاملون في مجال الرعايه
الصحيه في السودان يفعلون المستحيل يعتنون
بالجرحى بدون ماء وكهرباء وامدادات طبيه
اساسيه
منظمات غير حكوميه تبذل جهودا لانقاذ
القطاع الصحي في السودان في ظل المعارك
المتواصله
منظمه اطباء بلا حدود قالت انها تبرعت
بمستلزمات طبيه لثلاثه مستشفيات في
الخرطوم
ومن الصليب الاحمر وصلت اول شحنه من
الامدادات الطبيه الى السودان
وطائره ثانيه ستنقل امدادات طبيه اضافيه
وموظفين في مجال الطوارئ
ينضم الينا من الخرطوم دكتور محمد ابراهيم
عبد الرحمن المتحدث باسم وزاره الصحه في
السودان اهلا بك معنا الدكتور يعني هل
هناك
موافقه من قبلكم على الارقام التي تعلنها
نقابه الاطباء
والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله يحييكم
ويحيي المشاهد الكريم
ونحيي القطاع الصحي العريض الغطاء
[موسيقى]
الحكومي والخاص والمتطوعين الذين يمثلون
ملحمه الوطنيه في العمل في تقديم الخدمات
الصحيه في المستشفيات والمراكز العقيده
قيمه الخدمات الصحيه تحت هذه الظروف
بالنسبه لسؤالي دكتور لو سمحت نعم نعم هذه
الارقام التي طرحت
من الاجسام التي سميتموها منظمه
نقابه اطباء السودان على الواقع لا يوجد
ما يسمى بن غلطه السودان في السودان لا
يوجد جسم بهذا المسمى
اما الارقام التي طرحت من منظمه الصحه
العالميه فهي ارقام غير صحيحه منظمه الصحه
العالميه ايضا تستغي معلوماتها من منظمات
ليس لديها قاعده بيانات حقيقيه في النظام
الصحي في السودان هل هم يتحدثون عن نظام
الصحه الخرطوم والا في جميع ولايات
السودان ال18 ولايه هل يتحدثون
بموضوع الاشتباك مع النقابه لانه صار
معروف بس مع المنظمه ليش ما بتستقي
معلوماتها من وزاره الصحه
في موقع وزاره الصحه الاتحاديه وموضع
وزاره الصحه
وهنالك رسمي لا تصحح الاتحاديه باسم وزاره
الخرطوم ونحن نطلع على هذه القنوات مرارا
وتكرارا بس عفوا يعني انه في منظمه صحه
عالميه وفي وضع حرب يعني انتم تقولون له
روحه على جوجل يعني لحتى تشوفوا المعلومات
واجبكم انتم كووزاره انت تبلغوهم بذلك
اخي الكريم نحن ابو عمر المفتوحه ونحن
الجهه الرسميه والدستوريه والمسؤوله
والمسائله هذه الارقام المتجلات طبيه الان
على ارض القاضي اجسام غير مسؤوله وغير
مسائله
من وزاره الصحه الاتحاديه التي تتحدث عن
جميع السودان وزاره الصحه طب شو ارقامكم
عدد عدد الجرحى
الذي قادر عن
نقابه الاطباء السودان هو عدد قليل لا
يمثل الجرحك ولا تخرطوم ولا الجرحى في
السودان لانهم ليس لديهم قاعده البيانات
حقيقيه
طيب
النقابه حكيت عن 2175 طب هذه الموثقين يا
دكتور ما هو باي حرب هيك بصير بيحكوا عن
الموثقين واللي مش قادرين يوثقوهم ما
بيحصروهم يعني ولا انتم قادرين تحصروهم
يعني على الاقل بيعطوا رقم مبدا عن
المحصوره في المستشفيات
انا لا اتحدث عن اذا هم
اكثر دقه يبقى مهما يكونوا مرجعي انا
اتكلم عن الاليات التي المستشفيات
والمراكز معلوماتهم عن المستشفيات خاطئه
ما ارقامكم الرسميه الان بخصوص القتلى
بعيدا عن الاشتباك السياسي بين الطرفين
الان بينكم وبين نقابه الاطباء الكريم
كيف يكون ذلك مهنيا وانت لا تعترف حتى
بنقابه الاطباء في بلدك
بنقابه الاطباء لا يوجد على الجسم شرعي
اسمه نقابه اطباء لا يوجد
يعني كيف لا يوجد الاطباء نقابه عريقه جدا
في السودان طول عمرها مسؤوله عن كانت يعني
ثورات كانت تقوم على ظهرها احيانا في
السودان يعني كيف الان تنكر دورها
هنالك نظام معتمد لتكوين النقابات
هنالك نظام معتمد لتكوين النغبات هنالك
اربع ايام تظهر في هذه القناه اللجنه
التمهيديه لنقابه الاطباء السودان نقابه
السودان المكتب الموحد لنقابه اطباق
السودان اللجنه المركزيه لنقابه اطباء
السودان هل يعقل هذا
ان كانت هذه الاجزاء على ارض الواقع
المتاحه نحن نجدكم عبرها نناشدها نناشد
هذه الاجسام عبركوا ان ينزلوا الى
المستشفيات والمراكز الصحيه اذا كانوا هم
جزء من هذا النظام الصحي اذا كان هذه
الصوره وصلت وهي برسم نقابه الاطباء اذا
الان وهم مخولون بالرد عليها انشاؤه عبر
منابر العربيه تمام
والمتطوعين وصلت نظرك هي برسم نقابه
الاطباء الان ان ارادوا الرد عبر منابر
العربيه الان عدد القتلى لديكم كم في
الوزاره
الذي جاء الى المستشفيات العامله عدد
المصابين 3,03
1288 في المستشفيات الحكوميه
و1,715 في القطاع الخاص هذه الاعداد
بالارقام والسجلات الطبيه
ايوه تحدث عن الذين جاؤوا مستشفين في
المستشفيات
الوفيات 206 وفاء موفقه هذه التي اتت الى
المستشفى
بس هذه ايضا انت تقول انه غير نهائيه لانه
لا يمكن الحصر الان يعني هذه ارقام غير
نعم لانه يعني تبدو قد يبدو العدد اكبر
بظل الوضع عم يعيشوا البلد لا ننقل هذا
طيب بموضوع انه 69% من المستشفيات
المتاخمه
لمناطق الاشتباكات
في القطاع الخاص هنالك عدد من المراكز
الصحيه التي تعمل الان 51 مركز صحي مرجعي
يقدم خدمات الحالات البارده والامراض
المزمنه على على على مستوى تبع محليات
الان في مناطق امنه من مجمل 81 مركز صحي
من المستشفيات
المتاخمه لمناطق الاشتباكات بدك تسمعني
دكتور محمد لو سمحت
دكتور محمد عم تسمعني قالت نقابه اطباء
سوداني انه 69% من المستشفيات المتاخمه
لمناطق الاشتباكات التي قامت بحصرها
متوقفه عن الخدمه هذا كمان مش صحيح
هذه النسبه
كم عدد المستشفيات التي لها المقام
65% من
مستشفى من المستشفيات المتاخمه لمناطق
الاشتباكات بكل الخرطوم يعني والخرطوم
بحري واندر مان واضح الكلام هذه عدم
مستشفيات ولايه الخرطوم 134 مستشفى
على القطاع العام والغطاء الخاص 54 مستشفى
القطاع العام 81 مستشفى القطاع الخاص
وهنالك 11 مستشفى تتبع للجيش والشرطه
والامن والجامعات غير محصوله في 134
مستشفى العامل الان عدد المسيفات التي
تعمل الان بكفاءه
الحد الادنى الذي يقدم الخدمه الطارئه
وشبه الطارئه لجرحى الحرب والاغراض
المزمنه هي 95 مستشفى تعمل بالحد الادنى
من الدوائر والادويه متوفره فيها يعني
الوضع جيد ليس جيدا ولكن ليس بالسوء الذي
تتحدث عنه نقابه الاطباء
تقديم الخدمات الصحيه للوضع الذي يحمي
الحي ويقدم الخدمه الخطره وشبه الخطره
واللي عم نشوفهم على وسائل التواصل يموتون
بسبب قله الادويه
كانت موجوده على
المستشفيات طيب ومن نرى على وسائل التواصل
انهم يموتون بسبب نقص الادويه
اذا الحديث عن انهيار غير وارد ولا
يه من مجموع من مجموعه السودان دكتور محمد
ابراهيم عبد الرحمن المتحدث باسم وزاره
الصحه في السودان من الخرطوم شكرا جزيلا
على وجودك معنا في هذه التغطيه متواصله من
العربيه ولانا لقاءات اخرى ان شاء الله
نتمنى ان يصبح الوضع افضل مما يقوله
الطرفان
والله هذا يعني شعور لا يوصف ان الواحد
يكون كله يعني قوه والاسره كلهم بامان
الناس كثير هناك عندها مشاكل ما قادره ما
عندها فلوس ما عندها مصاري ناس كتير معلقه
نحمد الله سبحانه
لاهل المملكه هل هذا الاستقبال
[موسيقى]
عاشرونا الف لاجئ سودانيه يعانون مراره
اللجوء في تشاد اغلبيتهم من النساء
والاطفال منهم من يعاني من امراض تنفسيه
خطيره غير ان اليونيسيف حذرت من البقاء في
تشاد خوفا من موسم الامطار المقبل
نهايتها عصيه طريق اللجوء يطول وصلنا
وحدات الى تشاد لاجئه سودانيه دون مواعيد
بعضهن تمكنا من الدفع فقلى عليهن عبئ
الطريق نساء واطفال هربوا من حرب اشتعلت
فجاه خيار اللجوء لا مفر منه ضمن حرب
بحصيله كبيره للقتله
ثلاثه نفر اربعه كده عشان كده
استقروا هنا على الحدود التشاديه
السودانيه كبرات السن لم تعد لهن القدره
على المضي بينما الاطفال اغلبهم يعانون من
امراض تنفسيه وسوء تغذيه
20 الف لاجئ سوداني استقروا في قريه كفرون
تشاديه قريه تفتقر لاساسيات الحياه وضروره
تغيير المكان باتت حتميه
اذا فشلنا في التحرك الان سيفوت الاوان
سياتي موسم الامطار قريبا واذا لم نقدم
مساعده للناس سيتم اغلاق الطريق وسيظل
اللاجئون عالقين هنا
يبدو ان البقاء هنا طويل مخيم اللجوء باتت
تتشكل ملامحه عشرات الاسقف واعمده علها
تشد بيت لاجئ الى حين عوده غيداء السالم
العربيه
في مشهد مؤثر لعمليه اجلاء نقل افراد من
البحريه السعوديه شابا من ذوي الاحتياجات
الخاصه من ميناء بورتسودان وتم نقله الى
سطح سفينه الدرعيه المتجهه الى جده
على مهلك على مهلك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
العربيه الثالث